I was just going to respond in the sense
that there was conversation that keeps
coming up over lunch obviously
especially among the physicists that
there is a role for philosophy of
science that's actually right there deep
in the physics sometimes and and and
that would be for instance and they
Simon's talked about this and Sean and
Stephen and I touched by this in things
like the interpretation of quantum
mechanics where physicists really don't
have a handle on what's going on right
we can operationally do what we do with
equations it's fantastically tested
paradigm but it's not one that we
actually in any forward-thinking sense
understand right both but I think people
like David Albert who call themselves
philosophers of science who also you
know he does have a physics degree and
all of that but is very much on that
cusp I think that some sense Dunn is
describing an economics and philosophy
that people are very much on that cusp
is pressing people to think harder but
what do you mean by the collapse of the
wavefunction what do you mean by the
many-worlds interpretation and if we
keep scratching at this one area where
we clearly have a massive gap in our
comprehension maybe we'll make an actual
real-life physical discovery and I think
that's a genuine place yes we have very
clear examples where philosophy of
physics is helped and it may continue in
things like the landscape and what we
won't go into it all now but in that
sense it's a little maybe closer to
David's you know hope and that it it it
gives people who are on that cusp of
trying to understand fundamental physics
some tools and changes the goal poet
moves a gold pose
biology yeah almost everyone the highest
level of evolutionary biology recognizes
the name Samir Akasha
because even right Samira levels of
selection problem and the relevance of
crisis equation to this debate in a way
that at any rate I've heard scientists
on BBC say well we're not gonna solve
this problem we have to leave it to
simmer okay I know oh and what's to say
something but also not to unfairly
demand that the scientists have a right
to tell the Philosopher's what they
ought to be right we don't have to say
look this would be better for us you
better give us what we need right you
obviously have your own programs as I
think Massimo laid out but Owen I don't
think there's any general answer to the
question of what's the intellectual
division of labor and how should it work
I think there's you know the fact that
Alec says everybody knows Sameera kosha
and in the most distinguished
evolutionary biologist in the room
doesn't know Sameera I think I feel that
I don't have an interesting perspective
from that one of you because I've done
both we were talking and you know some
of the discussions going on about well
do philosopher I mean do science really
need philosophers to come up with these
this view of broader view of whatever
sometimes yes sometimes no let's not
forget that the practice is in fact very
different when I was a scientist
especially in the last 10 years most of
my time was spent writing damn grant
proposals okay because the funding rate
at NSF is 5% at this point so so it was
right
so it's ridiculous now what that means
is you know you put that one on top of
course that you're teaching your duties
and your graduate students which and the
interaction with migrations was much
more intense as a scientist than as a
philosophy and as a philosopher you know
what I do with my graduate students I'll
see you the next Thursday at a wine bar
and we'll chat for a couple of hours and
that's about it
as a scientist everyday you're in the
lab every day you have to solve
practical problems there is field work
to be done there is data analysis it's a
bunch of stuff which does not afford
most scientists until they until they
take a sabbatical or until they get you
know close to retirement and start doing
philosophy
as Gerry actually once pointed out
during a seminar at Stony Brook when I
was there you just don't have the luxury
of stepping back and taking a broad look
at a large amount of literature in in a
in different fields and say oh let me
see what I think about it the
Philosopher's if they do their job right
which clearly it's not always the case
had that like it's not the luxury that's
that's what they do they don't have to
write grant proposals mostly they don't
have laboratories mostly they don't have
graduate students that pastured them
every day they do have usually more
teaching to do but whatever so so the
intellectual division of labor it's not
just intellectual it's practical it's a
matter of you know there's only so many
hours in the day and there's only so
many things you can do and so why not
take advantage enough David that doesn't
mean again that you what couldn't I
figured out that that one is a bad idea
yes of course you can but there may be
other things you didn't pay attention or
you're not thinking about because you
got busy doing other stuff and so if
somebody comes in from the outside and
says hey have you noticed that yeah I
just thought it might be useful to flesh
out the example of the interpretation of
quantum mechanics as a place where
philosophers have been useful and and in
thinking about it since I didn't since I
had to think the last five minutes also
a place where philosophers sort of
dropped the ball a little bit because
they could have been useful earlier
right and it's clear why the different
communities play different roles because
the scientists very often and for very
good reasons
want to figure out what happens and then
later we'll figure out what it means
right and so if quantum mechanics is a
great example where we had this this
half-baked formalism of the Copenhagen
interpretation and then you know there's
a classical world that observes the
quantum world and that was good enough
for many many years for really
describing the experiments and people
playing out that it wasn't really good
enough cuz it made no sense but it still
was okay and it's only in recent last
couple decades that there's been a lot
more discussion about that and partly it
was the Philosopher's pressing on it and
part but a crucial role was actually
played by physics because our
experiments are able to probe at what
used to be the inaccessible boundary of
the quantum
bicycle so we could make an anti
philosophical argument that you know
back in the 1930s the philosophers could
have really just insisted that this was
making no sense and tried to do better
but now that we need to do better
because the experiments are pushing us
that way the philosophers have been very
very useful in explaining mistakes that
you know the scientists have been
tempted into so there's the many-worlds
interpretation which just says the wave
function evolves and it splits into
different worlds and there are bad
objections to that which the
philosophers have that objection
there are also better effect yeah but
there are bad objections like there's
too many universes central bad
objections right exactly but then there
are also again since the scientists want
to say well I want to figure out what
works and then we'll get to the details
later
you know the idea of deriving the
probability rule the fact that the
probability of getting a result is the
wave function squared a lot of
physicists would just say well let's
just add that on to the effort
interpretation of quantum mechanics to
the menu rule let's write it down as a
postulate and it is the philosophers who
have been saying no you can't do that it
doesn't make logical sense it's against
the other it's not quite it doesn't fit
in with the other rules and in fact
they're the ones who press on the need
to understand what's going on because on
the one hand the many-worlds
interpretation doesn't have
probabilities in it anywhere and some of
the scientists who think they're doing
the you know the hard work of deriving
the probability rule from the
many-worlds interpretation what they're
really saying is if there is a rule for
probabilities it must be this one and
put that and that's kind of the easy
part and the hard part is explaining why
it's a theory of probability at all and
that's exactly in the philosophers
wheelhouse to sort of you know address
that question in a deep way
now you might at the end of the day say
okay and if this philosophical nudge
moves us to a better understanding of
quantum mechanics I don't care because I
still know how to calculate things in
quantum mechanics but I think that if it
if it does it sort of immediately gets
absorbed
into what we consider the useful physics
research program you know what kinds of
experiments teach us something when we
have entangled quantum states very very
is that are making that assertion yes I
am I'm making the assertion that we
understand more about the universe now
than we did before without the presence
of academic Foster's in physics so I
didn't quite understand that sentence I
mean you say it didn't really matter to
you whether the progress of science was
had where the science have progressed
more or because of the leak operations
of academic laws I'm saying that young
and philosophers missed a chance in the
earlier years of the 20th century to
have a big impact on the development of
quantum mechanics but now they are
having a big impact on the development
of quantum mechanics and I think that
they will you know they didn't listen to
John exactly right John Bell made great
advances they a fortiori that's a good
idea you know they could have just done
it I mean that oh it wasn't a matter of
needing new data right you know yeah we
knew enough to come up with a federal
education and
good point that until you really get
your foot stuck in a track you might not
turn to help so I want you to point out
something I don't know if it's so much
about philosophers and scientists but
philosophy and science and that is that
um philosophy is damn hard to do and
it's particularly hard
we all have philosophical intuitions I
was very you know impressed with your
saying something which i think is true
about cognitive science yes deep down
they're relying on Cartesian dualism
it's a very flossy something that most
of us don't want to think about even
philosophers right you've got your
intuitions and until you really run into
trouble with them you know they're just
buried down there and they're
percolating up and they're there um and
scientists this is very true for as well
in fact that conversation I had that for
me pivotal conversation with any more
investor when I was an undergraduate
when he convinced me to go into
philosophy of science rather than a
philosophy and he said you know uh
rather than physics connect between the
brakeman in the word yeah but what he
said was you know um scientists are a
capitalist right it works and they just
keep going and you know philosophers are
communists I mean they're constantly
rethinking the basic system and they're
keeping it you know the questions are
always on the table there and do you
wanna you know do you want do you want
to be a capitalist or communist then
this was the 1970s and my answer was
clear no every one of it but um the
thing is that bad philosophy creeps in
to physics all the time in the case that
I particularly think of as more than you
really Boltzmann right I mean that he
presents a fantastic
you know solution to the arrow of time
and nobody buys it because they're all
they got bad philosophy the whole
scientific community has bad philosophy
and so it you know it's really the role
of philosophers to just keep these
questions this is an open question and
to just keep pushing this that these
questions are are open and that it does
affect a can affect and impede little
times in the history of science advances
philosophers I think just have to be
used to the fact that until they find
their foot trapped they're gonna be very
rude about our attempts to move in and
say wait a minute wait a minute
I don't think you're clear about this I
mean I think much the same thing
happened with consciousness after 1990
suddenly everybody's writing a book
about consciousness and Crick and
DiMaggio and Lena and you and Christoph
concert everybody's got to have their
book on consciousness and they try to
write these books and then they think oh
this is hard
and and they stumble around and you know
most of those books are pretty bad and
the good thing that's come out of that
for us philosophers is that there's a
lot of much more modest people in
cognitive science and neuroscience now
than they used to be because they've
kind of realized that they do not have a
handle on how the top
consciousness and just to pile on that
side of the argument it when
philosophers do make a very helpful
intervention and set things straight a
little bit the reaction of the
scientists will be oh yes I get it now
and then that's obvious I knew that all
along right and they never remembered
they do that to each other I mean you
know my hope is that one day somebody
says that's obvious because that means I
penetrated great like half you're gonna
think this is trivial laughter you're
gonna think it's complete nonsense I'm
just trying to move people from the
nonsense to the trivia
well I'll of to criticize my colleagues
I just want to you know play it
diplomatic go for a second and say that
sometimes the rudeness in fairness is
coming from very vocal very prominent
few and actually I think most scientists
feel very humbled by their field
honestly and and and are more respectful
of people I agree with 100 cent not not
even philosophers want to talk about
floss think about flus we have time
because it's so hard I mean I am very
aware that sometimes in my own work I'll
rub into something which is getting into
that issue and I just I want to go
calculate because it's so much more
pleasant I know I'm gonna get somewhere
in the end it's like washing dishes I
know it's gonna be done you know and and
so I think that most centers are more
receptive maybe though less vocal
you